racism is around us
in our societies racism is in our
streets
in our workplaces and at times even in
our institutions
europe must be better than this it is
for this reason
that last year the commission adopted
the first
ever eu anti-racism action plan
we were inspired by the many europeans
who took to the street
shouting that black lives matter here in
europe too
the first step was to organize the first
ever
european anti-racism summit
today's event because we must
keep talking about racism in europe we
must hear
from the people and the associations
working on the ground
every day we need to send a strong
message against racism all across our
union
including when necessary by means of
criminal law
it's plain and simple
in our union using race and color
as a slur is not free speech
it's a criminal offence it is european
law
which member states must transpose
in full in their national legislation
anti-racism is a founding principle of
our union
and it is a red threat running through
70 years of history
in the late 90s 80 000 european students
were asked to choose a motto for our
union
and after a long selection process
they came up with unity
in diversity it was just perfect
in just three words they summed up
our union's reson d'etre
and our greatest aspiration
our starting point and our destination